[Music]
hello and welcome to episode 45 of
GameSpot after dark game spots official
video game podcast joining me this week
is Callie plaguey well Michael hi I'm
what up and Khalif Adams of spawn on me
we've been trying to get you on for a
while how you doing I'm good I'm super
excited to rock with you all today I am
very very happy to be chilling and doing
this show because I love you all I love
your work you've all been fantastic in
this place so get the chance to hang out
with y'all is gonna be really really
dope well we're happy to have you here I
think I think I can speak for a lot of
us too by saying we love your work as
well and we're very happy to get this
going like words it's gonna be a good
episode
oh yeah cuz you're here and also because
there is a big game that we are allowed
to talk about but we have to be very
careful what we say about it because I
feel like talking about this game is
gonna be like walking through a
minefield so yeah yeah we'll be very
careful but we normally start this show
with a segment called the Chris from
Dayton Ohio segment and this is where
our guest explains who they are what
they do and their favorite games Callie
really wants to sing the little song so
go ahead but we don't do that that much
anymore because since we've been doing
this since kovat and everyone's been
stuck at home we've been kind of not
really doing guests mostly because I
don't know what the hell I'm doing half
the time but we finally got it working
but anyway Khalif who are you I am
Khalif Adams I am the runner the owner
the producer the on-air talent for the
swallow me podcast the premiere podcast
spotlighting people of color in the
video game industry we've been doing
that show for about six years now in my
day job I work over Intel in their
community department I guess that's the
way you'd want to call that and yeah I'm
from the Bronx New York I'm out in
Portland Oregon and kicking kicking
behind out here in the gaming industry
trying to be X all day everybody BX all
day what up I got my Tim's on underneath
his desk
but it's real in the feel right now what
about games like what what what are some
games consoles or whatever that you you
all contacts can leave the original
email we got from Chris from Dayton Ohio
I'm telling the story people who have
been listening I'm sorry you've heard it
a thousand times by now but the question
posed to us by Chris from Dayton Ohio
was who the hell are you I don't know
who the hell I think they were a Giant
Bomb listener and Giant Bomb ran ads for
this podcast in there just like alright
another podcast I'll give it a listen
god I felt that so hard
and the question included like what
games are like your tentpole games what
games you return to so that's that's the
context there also that sounds like an
email that my mother would send me like
who the hell are you what are you doing
it what do you want here games that I
love I'm a huge metal gear fan I love
that series that's something that I've
always enjoyed and really have loved I
love old-school titles like real
old-school like one of my favorite games
on the planet is running gun from Konami
because I'm a child of the arcade era so
that is a huge part of my life big
fighting game fan so I love Mortal
Kombat that's my favorite series I'm a
huge Mk fan and I like kind of offshoot
games that too is like I love music
excuse me music games as well a game
that most people don't know about or
haven't paid attention to that is one of
my favorite of all time is a game from q
games called 4 a.m. that came out some
years ago on the ps3 which was a music a
kind of performance game that no one
really bought but it was super dope it
was like we usually move controllers it
was like spatial in the way did you kind
of manipulated the audio and you had an
audience that would watch you but you
couldn't see them so they were kind of
just like bar graphs on a screen and
when you saw them get really excited
then the bar graphs were kind of raised
up and down definitely go check that out
it's on YouTube somewhere you can
definitely find that out but he was it
was one of my favorite games so lots of
different things and lots of different
genres for in terms of games that I
loved
just to bring it back a little bit to
Kojima and Metal Gear and stuff one
thing that I think I forgot to tell you
is that you helped me a lot in death
stranding I don't know if I remember
going through that game be like oh
that's Khalif that's cool
oh yeah I mean I love that game I know
people hate on that thing god I love
that game
oh yeah that game desu training is super
dope like you know and that was one of
the things that took away from that game
was like I'm actually doing something
and helping someone else out in the
space or like if I can help do that and
this game is for me I'm totally down to
do that stuff so I am very happy that I
got to help you cross all those muddy
waters and all those ravines and getting
it to where you needed to go that game
is just so like earnest what an earnest
like heartfelt game yeah for sure oh it
was good sure I just want to say one
thing about spawning me for the audience
that might the game spot after dark
audience that might not know about it so
I'm gonna I'm gonna pitch it to them is
that y'all should be listening to spawn
on you not because not because I was on
it or anything but I have actually been
a fan I talked about this on the episode
but I've been a fan of spawning me
myself and I can vouch for COD when he
says that y'all should be listening to
spawn on me
it's actually I Daniel dryer put me on
when he cuz you were on the lobby in
2016 I'm old schools who gamespot baby
let's go yeah it was uau and reef during
GDC 2016 I saw I saw both y'all on Lobby
and I was like oh I gotta check out
spawn on me so I was with him since I
was there I was like I was still an
intern so my head was down just editing
things I don't remember anything
oh wow shut up shut up - Mary kitchen
Erik Tay for rocking the booth that day
and making it all dope yeah that was
that was a surreal moment and massive
luck to Danny who I love with my whole
heart for bringing us on it and having
that conversation because honestly that
was one of our that was really our big
break in a lot of ways where we got a
chance to be on a major stage like that
having really good conversations about
what we do so I owe Danny
much more
much love for fur giving us the chance
to do that work yeah Danny's great i
selfish we miss working with him
although he's doing like so much great
stuff with noclip and whatnot it still
matters still some days or I'm like man
I wish Danny was still here but I mean I
guess just a quick plug is the play for
all stream we're doing he's actually
gonna be on the stream on Friday and
we're gonna play like skateboarding
games Tony Hawk maybe skate all you talk
about at the end but Danny will be on
gamespot again very soon but anyway
let's move on to what we've been playing
Michael do you want to kick this off I
figure we'll save last of us sure last
yeah I think that makes sense so I mean
I don't have too much more to say since
last week I did put up my Valor
intervene progress and I see that Jake
you been playing Valerie what the hell
Wow Wow I totally forgot wow-whee
reporting news man it's not he's not
toxic but but anyway yeah I've been
playing more Valerie because I need to
finalize that review which will I I will
be doing this week and I've I've the
more I play the agents the more I
understand their their specialties in a
match like how to use them and how to
use their powers in relation to your
other teammates
because I think that's where the where
the depth and where your success kind of
comes out of is not just understanding
your how you use your your own agent but
how you use in conjunction with everyone
else mm-hm and when those things happen
like Valerie's psyche it's just hitting
on all cylinders and some some nights
you just got rack up hella double use
other nights nothing but else that's
kind of just how it is man like it's
something that I think folks should
understand going into Valerie if they
don't haven't experienced yes in any
sort of way and that [ __ ] can be hella
frustrating but when the game is
clicking it's it's really clicking but
like I said last week it's fairly
bare-bones it's four maps one mode the
agents are I like how they function some
of them just
aren't for me but I see other players
playing as them in effective ways but I
found it like a the four or five agents
that I definitely like I know that I can
get a grip with them and find some
success also what I'm starting to learn
too is that certain agents are very
effective on certain maps mmm that's
does that was a cool really nice
realization a little bit of a more
tactical layer but overall I like it
quite a bit but I said this in my review
in progress that it has so much
potential to be great it's just not
there yet but the foundation is very
strong like that game is a lot of fun
and frustrating in equal ways but you
kind of understand that going into it
yeah what was your experience like been
so far outside of uh spawning noobs I
mean it's me who never played csgo I
immediately was pretty interested in it
just because I mean sure of a tactical
shooters before like I play a lot of
Rainbow six siege but it it was
different it felt very different and I'm
enjoying learning that style of tactical
shooter I guess there are still some
things that I feel like half the agents
abilities is to throw down a colored
ball of smoke that's every game it's
like I've got green smoke balls I've got
white smoke balls I've got purple smoke
balls and it's just like okay or it's a
it's a it's a wall that someone throws
down which I think are great like it's a
lot of fun using those abilities to your
advantage and how you can place them in
different areas and how you can pretty
much just cut off entire sides of the
map like that's pretty fun but I still I
stick to
I think sage and Raina and that's about
it that's all I can do yeah but I'm
having fun overall I think you're
totally right though there there's a lot
that I want to see in this game Maps in
particular because there are four maps
one of which I've only played once which
is split I think and I've played the
other ones a ton and yeah I'm already
kind of tired oven and maybe that is
partly because playing a lot of siege
like those maps are so dynamic and they
change so much depending on where you're
starting where you're attacking like
what operators you habré's yeah
blow open well this is like alright we
do an a B or C or some maps just a or B
which it's fine but I just I need more
maps I think I need more maps and I also
need to get good but that's it I think
in the in the age of Rainbow six siege
that I love like counter-strike is my
[ __ ] 100% that's always gonna be my
favorite multiplayer game but in the age
of Rainbow six siege I think it's it's
they're going for a certain thing
they're nailing it but it's not going to
click with some folks especially if they
play just be sure to read our updated
review of Rainbow six siege on GameSpot
calm it got an essential ten out of ten
that's what I'm saying I think but you
should also read Michaels Valor review
which wasn't finalized probably by the
time you listen to a podcast uh since
Kelly's on this podcast I'm gonna update
her on where I am at peace with pso2 if
you had a chance to play sure yeah oh
yeah I think I think valor in should
have a a notification or a disclaimer on
on the digital code that says if you're
over 40 you should not play this game if
you and your eye hand coordination be an
old fam yeah I played it for like three
days and was like nah I can't do it like
well plus I have to have to disclaimer I
am new to PC gaming in a real way so
like I am a console junkie in that way
and have moved over to PC so keyboard
and mouse I'm still learning how to
actually like function in a reasonable
way while doing that so it is amazingly
frustrating to try to play a game that
is so so dependent on your eye hand
coordination with a mouse and keyboard
to be able to play that stuff but I did
have fun in some of the matches when we
were winning when we're losing I was
like I'm just old I don't know what to
do like I can't I can't
like Shang Tsung myself into being
younger and then figure out
how to actually have skills to do this
thing so it's fun though I appreciate
what people are able to do it actually
gives me a lot more love for people who
have figured out how to play on Mouse
and keys and have been good for a long
time and that stuff's give me a bigger
appreciation for that for sure like I am
no longer like you keyboard mouse people
are cheating I'm like no you have lots
of skills and I can't get that yet so
it's this pretty dope I actually went
through something similar because I
never played PC until I started working
at GameSpot and I was like I mean I
should probably figure this out and get
on board and what helped me a lot
actually was playing through the
Wolfenstein and doom games on PC yes I
could manipulate difficulty I could
change the keys and like it was it was
somewhat forgiving but it also was
pretty difficult so like and I think the
checkpoints especially in Wolfenstein
are pretty generous
so that actually helped me a lot I still
suck with mouse and keyboard but I
recommend checking out some of those
like it's software Bethesda shooters
because for some reason those really
nailed the whole mouse and keyboard
setup in my head yeah for sure for sure
I played a little bit of doom doom
eternal with Mouse and keys and made
sure not to stream myself playing that
well cuz that he did not need that heat
in the chat so but totally good good
recommendation for that yeah I mean
quake have like it's off our games have
that legacy on PC to which which to me
makes them feel really appropriate
I played doom 64 so I played that with a
controller with my 8 my dad played a lot
of quake and head mods and stuff back in
the day and like quakes they were like a
big part of the reason pcs come with
graphics cards now like a graphics card
as a thing you and PCs so like that that
legacy it kind of feels right just like
in your spirit yeah play those games on
PC also but I like the my PC habits just
are wholly dependent on my living
situation because I had to switch to PC
completely in college because I couldn't
fit a TV in my room properly so that I
played like Skyrim on PC and stuff and
that was very weird what what button is
the force do Ron on a keyboard is it
like like X
yeah it's something weird just be a
function key just to [ __ ] with you for
why anyway Callie's dad is also our Call
of Duty correspondent by the way
occasionally he'll come on the podcast
just just to tell us what he thinks of
the new updates oh that's that's though
yeah
my dad has a storied history with
shooters and now he gets to see that
black lives matter splash screen and he
logs in so that's pretty dope mm-hmm how
I mean yes Call of Duty is a vehicle for
the US military a recruitment vehicle
but pretty cool that like my dad sees
that when logging in yeah oh yeah a lot
of reach so yeah I mean like yes I will
I know people have been talking about
well it is kind of like this tool for
the US military is like I acknowledge
that look but it's been really cool that
like that's on the main TV in my parents
house if it makes little ten-year-old
Brent have to go ask his parents about
what black glass matters is that is a
win go do it Chandler go do it Brent go
make all rice makes it Bryson go do that
make that conversation happen that is a
win for us I don't care anyway Michael
you were going to give my rather have
all that happen already talked about
pso2 like took it in six different
tangents I love that [ __ ] I love it
that's what we're known for
the context here is that Michael is a
machine and is working on not one but
two reviews due to him being both a
shooter expert a csgo boy and an anime
no no I call Jordan he's Jordan his
anime King I'm like anime apprentice cuz
I wanna see yeah sure like he calls
himself that but actually that's me cuz
like you actually cally has been
very of instrumental in my my transition
into the weed world nod I hate to see it
I love to see it
[ __ ] you talking about you love to see
it but yeah pso2 man i you know i i've
been seeking a lot of time into valor
and i've been doing a lot of things out
in the world during this time so i
haven't had like that much time more
time to put into pso2 but again they're
getting there it's kind of I mean I know
my review and progress is not up yet but
I don't think that game is great I
appreciate that it exists and that has
been localized 10 years later but you
talk about like games trying to
understand how to play games on a
keyboard and mouse just trying to
understand how to navigate that game has
been a pain and I'm probably like I
think I'm like level 40 something at
this point cap is 75 so I'm pretty deep
into it but there's so much going on
that it is like a product not of 2010
but it's a product of like the mid 2000s
that it just has so many systems in
place that aren't facilitated well but I
mean it's fun and it's got an amazing
date in the goro majima skin so I'm down
with that
next Wednesday next Wednesday is gonna
be a Vocaloid concert so you're gonna
see Miku and Luca in there so I mean
you'll love to see that yeah I'd love to
see that but I don't know it's so
pulling away a PSN to you and then on
the flip side and MMO that is much much
better in my opinion not to hate on pso2
but during these times I think it's very
important to find comfort when you can
and I think that I find a lot of comfort
in persona games and particularly Final
Fantasy 14 I've talked about it many
times on this podcast and I will
continue to talk about it for the rest
of my life that Final Fantasy 14 brings
me great comfort in many ways because
it's
I mean it's an MMO so it feels like a
home and when you invest 500 plus hours
in an ax and an MMO it will feel like a
home so it's really really soothing to
go back to that world listen to the love
that music and then hit up the free
company but like hey what's good fam ah
you know what it is and just like live
in that world again and there's some
folks who are still going through - and
I think yeah I reflect on particularly
the particularly the expansion storm
blood final 5 C 14 storm blood is about
starting a revolution and overthrowing
your oppressors and back then when I
played it back then last year when I
played it you talked about it on this
podcast yeah I cry almost cry about it
and that wasn't a year ago it was last
year but not a year ago yeah yeah and I
think about that a lot and just how bold
the messages are in Final Fantasy 14 for
an MMO and how how its story like puts
his foot down and says [ __ ] this [ __ ]
eat the rich overthrow the government
and defeat attack and dethrone God that
is literally every final fantasy but
Final Fantasy 14 in particular you
attack and dethrone God multiple times
and that's that on that that's that on
that I killed my time I kind of love
that someone can walk up to Mike and say
so when were you radicalized and you
were like y'all talked about that we
talked about exactly's like yes o to
five and Final Fantasy 14 Radu
radicalized me I want that to be your
protest side you walk out into the
streets of like yo I was radicalized by
[Laughter]
steam keys on my on my side I said this
is John Luke I saw a protest sign that
was like I could be playing shin megami
tensei right now
so good folks need to get their [ __ ] I
was like this is a little bit more oh no
not you gently Oh oh yeah he's an SMT
boy in it respect mm-hmm that's amazing
taken to the streets also so but I will
not talk about that here the case the
feds try and track me down anyway I
yield my time Khalif you've been playing
disintegration as well which is a game
that we should probably talk about a
little bit cuz that comes out soon
pretty soon I think comes out next week
are we gonna have to talk about it we
are these are up the embodiment lifted
this morning being Wednesday and the
game comes out the 16th 16th yeah all
right okay yeah super super fun game
really diggin it we had a will be doing
a an interview with Markus Leto
coming up tomorrow on our twitch stream
so we'll be doing that front page at
which have that up and play some some
single-player stuff but yeah it's it's
this really interesting hybrid of a
first-person shooter in an RTS game
which i think was something I hadn't
seen before
and and the quick TL DR is that it's
pretty damn good look I'm diggin it and
finding out that I didn't know this was
a game that I was going to like I was in
this space where I don't have a MOBA to
play that feels good because Paragon is
dead rest in peace Paragon shall set the
Paragon Matt Paragon son oh and that
that was my game of choice for a very
long time
and I'm still finding I'm still looking
for something to fill that void and I
feel like this integration may be that
thing for me that's gonna fill that
space where you can have the
competitiveness of an MP shooter but
also have a reasonable single-player
campaign that also has like really
interesting commentary about humans and
the way they interact with each other
and the way they interact with the world
so those lows check off a whole bunch of
boxes for me for things that I like so
I'm excited to dig into more of it I
played some of the single-player but
kind of holding off until we do the
livestreams liking like have an actual
like in real-time reaction to the things
I'm gonna be playing so yeah it's pretty
dope so far I'm diggin it we have a
review up now and by Mike Epstein
freelancer for us and he liked it it
sounds really interesting and one of the
things that stuck out to me about the
review was he was talking about
different difficulty levels kind of
fine-tune whether you're doing more
strategy versus more FPS mm-hmm so like
if you lower the difficulty level it
becomes more of a shooter first and
foremost if the strategy element doesn't
go away but you can kind of fine-tune
how much FPS you want it to be in that
respect and I thought that was super
interesting so I'm really intrigued
sorry Jake you actually played it so
well I know I just played the beta and
and I wasn't super into the multiplayer
but I think it was like I was curious
about the world the world seemed
interesting but the multiplayer didn't
quite do it for me but what I was gonna
say is I think it's interesting that the
Markus little one of the Halo creators
is fusing fps and RTS when you look back
at the original pitch for halo 1 which
was an RTS game and they shifted to a
shooter so I think that's I don't know
kind of like an interesting full circle
there but also not really because kind
of taking cues from both genres so I'm
curious to play it like I am definitely
interested in what the story has to
offer I don't know if the multiplayer is
gonna be quite my thing but I I rarely
get into multiplayer games apart from
like Rainbow six and you know a little
bit of valor --nt now mm-hmm it's gonna
be interesting to see how the community
takes to it I feel like the folks who
are already kind of in those hybrid
spaces and looking for something that
may fit that mold they may be in for a
good treat it's just a matter of how
much you know how the community kind of
comes to it and how many people like
actually on servers because it is it is
a weird game where marketing for it is
out there but it does feel like it's not
getting the top billing that it probably
deserves yet so that's going to be a
hard thing to do with gay
that we're gonna talk about a little bit
coming out fairly soon too
so I figured they're gonna soak up a lot
of that energy that's gonna be there for
them so we'll see what one more thing
about this integration though cuz I when
I play the beta I felt like the the I
think there was only one mode that it
offered in terms of multiplayer mm-hmm
and I was like I get it but it felt a
little plain sure what is it how's the
competitive aspect likes the competive
multiplayer aspect bin I mean I haven't
played since the beta so I know they've
had some some press only nights where
people looked and gotten on it and got
some games and I just hadn't had a
chance to do any of those I know that
there's more than one mode now at least
there probably was but we just didn't
get a chance to play it in the beta but
there's a couple of modes in there I
think one's probably like the you know
kind of capture the flag bring it from
one place to another its you to the goal
line and you kind of have that tug of
war between the factions that are on the
field there's another one I just can't
remember which which one it was but I
think the the thing that's gonna push
that game forward is once people kind of
figure out what the the meta of that
game is going to be with the factions
that you're gonna wind up using because
each one has a very specific in kind of
a very specific use case once people
figure out what those are going to be
then people will try to figure out what
their gameplay styles are gonna wind up
being and then we'll see this stuff kind
of like puffery throughout throughout
the community to see how it's gonna work
so but we'll definitely have some time
because I feel like there is this
interesting gap between games right now
that we're gonna see where some folks
are definite gonna dip in and then put
their toes in there and see where
they're gonna land so well so we'll see
when it drops it's gonna be fun to see
what happens Kelly before we talk about
the Last of Us do you want to fill us in
on what you've been doing on Nick is on
yes I play Animal Crossing every day as
you well know and lately I've been
getting really into the meta of Animal
Crossing which takes place a little site
called nook is on it's a fan created web
site and it's super impressive
I was very resistant to it cursed mostly
because I'm like I should be getting
these items myself I should be patient
but no I'm like I want this DIY recipe
and
I want it right now so I started doing
it and I I think it's fascinating how it
works so basically you can go on the
website and like enter in every item
that you have and like from clothing to
furniture to like you out of curiosity
several hours so you can you can go
through your catalogue and see what
stuff you do have and then create a wish
list of things that you want and then
you can go through your wish list and
like say you want like a certain sofa or
something you can click on that sofa and
see everybody who is selling it and it's
it's never for real money it's like
in-game like you could pay bills or you
could pay with a nook miles tickets or
you can trade for wishlist items that
they have and so this is really
fascinating economy and etiquette on the
website so like I've had a lot of people
I've done a lot of trades so far in like
the last week and like everyone is
extremely respectful of your island like
people do not go past the first couple
steps unless you explicitly give them
permission I have this area at the I've
had it for a while this like free DIY
recipe area at the front of my Island
and nobody has touched it without me
being like oh by the way there's free
stuff here if you want it and then you
kissing yeah and then so so the thing
that I'm really into about it is think
about writing something about this is
like it is a it's a social platform like
there is a social element to it and you
connect with a lot of people that you
don't know but the interactions are
really positive and really respectful
and that's not something you always get
on Twitter calm for example so I have
been really just I have been obsessed
with it like one thing that people do is
like they'll review you after the trade
and at like as long as like the trade
goes smoothly nobody stole anything like
you'll get five stars and like people
we'll rate you and be like adorable
island thank you so much like it like
this is everybody on the website like
it's a culture of being like five stars
this person is trustworthy definitely
trade with them they were really nice
and it's just really wholesome and also
I'm getting like mad items so win-win
all around
I would highly recommend it if you
haven't tried it yet it takes a little
while like setup if you want to go
through and like enter your whole
catalog you don't have to do that you
can just enter your wish list and people
can trade with you but I found it to be
helpful in my keeping track of what I
have when doing trades I don't want to
like spend a bunch of money on an item
that I oh I already have this and
there's even like people will in list
like oh I have Celeste on my Island
today you can come over and get a recipe
from her or I have Sahara on my Island
come by like rugs and I've gone to
people's Islands for like their like
it's free just come you can come talk to
Celeste and like people are really
trusting and it has been so wholesome I
know it's like it's like next door but
for animal I part of it as it brings me
I used to be part of like Animal
Crossing forums and like the mid-2000s
so it brings me back to that it's like
the same energy of we're gonna trade
items and don't take my fruit like and
there's like a whole guide and it's mate
it's fan-made it's like fan-run discord
and they have a whole guide for like how
to trade safely how to protect yourself
how to like the proper etiquette like
because people put a lot of work into
their islands and I haven't done this
for many years being an animal crossing
player is you don't want someone coming
and [ __ ] with your Island so people
are very very conscious of like I'm not
gonna run in your flowers I'm not gonna
take any fruit and then what you can
offer it like oh please pick the fruit
and they're like are you sure like it's
just I kind of I kind of love that stuff
cuz I'm I'm an animal crossing noob so
my island is trash bag trash packs that
is there's like nothing on it it's just
like I just have [ __ ] just draw all over
the
at this point cuz I don't know what I'm
doing but I was over at I was over on
animal talking Gary Whitta show the
other day and you know you walk over to
where the set is a lot of stuff and and
I and I accidentally picked a flower and
I felt so bad I was like oh no like and
I have a thing with cemetry too so I'm
just like oh should I make you think
asymmetrical nassau like that like i
botched that thing and he was like it's
totally fine so be fine I felt like
seriously guilty for picking this
digital flower because I hit the wrong
button by accident and felt dirty I was
like yo I feel bad right now so I get it
that's not super cool I love the fact
that the communities kind of come around
that thing and it's found like an
interesting way to have a safe space in
a digital in a digital place yeah so
that's that's cool it's awesome I would
highly recommend it that's super cool
it's crazy to see how much that game
took off like I I figured Animal
Crossing would be a big success in fact
I was on the video team telling a lot of
people like hey we really have to cover
this game because it's gonna do well but
it's like it has gone so far beyond my
expectations of what I expected and I'm
sure Nintendo's to just like I mean even
like the fact that new Kazan is a thing
is is insane in the fact that like Gary
Whitta has started an incredibly
successful talks talk show all in the
game is insane and part of that is you
know due to the fact of what's going on
in the world right now but still like
it's it's absurd how big this game has
gotten especially like sure it was big
when I played on gamecube in 3ds and
whatnot but it was not the same it's not
the same at all it's a it's a social
phenomenon at this point yeah totally
for sure totally before we talked about
the last dose there's a couple things I
do want to point out not to say about it
I just want to like get a few things out
of the way if you're worried about
spoilers don't worry we're not gonna
talk about spoilers we're not gonna talk
about the story we're not allowed to so
you don't worry about any of that we are
just going to keep it very basic and
surface level I would say for now
however if you want to hear more in
depth thoughts we are going to do
spoiler chat once the embargo lifts or
once the game is out
excuse me once the game is out we'll do
a spoiler chat so make sure to tune in
for that and then the review goes up
Friday should be up today in theory and
doubts me no no I I'm still trying to
figure all this out of my head because
we're gonna have a spoiler free review
go up Friday and then we're gonna have a
not so much a spoiler review but it's
gonna be a review that digs more into
the story you can talk more about it
yeah I can yeah I just want to pitch
this because it is an unprecedented
thing that we're doing for the Last of
Us
I've never myself done a reviewing this
style but I think it serves the game
well I think it serves the audience
that's interested in this game but
really wants to just hey is it good or
is it not good with no spoilers that's
what this first review serves and that
will be the review that's up today and
then at launch I will have a more
detailed review for those who so it's
not gonna have like major spoilers but
there was going to be a little bit more
that maybe if you are you really want to
go in without any knowledge that's not
the review for you but this was this was
a really tough decision but I think that
the game warrants this approach I think
there's a lot to parse here and I would
hope that that second review that's
going up at launch will be something
that people will read when they've
finished the game and and kind of wanted
to sort through their feelings about it
that's really all I can say about that
reasoning but I through your feelings
you will yes I really hope that you guys
check out both reviews maybe that second
review is not going to do as well right
away because people want to play the
game but that is the approach and and I
should make it absolutely clear the
score is not going to be different the
score will not have the opportunity to
change between the today Friday and that
launch review it is the same score and
the same opinions just more detailed
because I feel that in being spoiler
completely spoiler free I really can't
express
myself the way that I need to for this
game so that's the thinking there's
going to be a very clear editor's note
and an explanation of that so hopefully
there's no confusion it's not like oh
and then it launched suddenly I'm
dropping the score it's like I gotcha in
that sense belief I noticed on Twitter
that you finished the game today yeah
while your thoughts are still fresh like
overall thoughts on the game it's this
is one of the hardest things I've ever
had to talk about because I swear I feel
like a soul eat Sony Illuminati he's
gonna jump out of a bush and try to
snatch me up if I say anything that
seems like it's gonna be like an actual
actual thing it's great it's a really
good game in a lot of different ways
that I didn't expect I feel like it does
some really good things with tying up
loose ends and I think it does you know
from a visual standpoint I was always
blown away from the cutscenes that they
showed throughout the the press releases
and kind of the lead-up to the game one
of things I left coming away from that
game thinking about was my god what does
this thing gonna look like on a PS 5
what is this thing gonna look like on
new hardware because if it looks like
this now on you know end of the life
cycles when you get the best of the best
usually now when you go and move into
new hardware what is this thing gonna
look like cuz I'm gonna be like alright
day one playing through this bad way
again because I have to do it because it
looks as good now it's gonna look even
better then I'm what I'm what I'm really
excited about actually is when people
get their hands on this thing because
there were a lot of questions from the
end of the last game that people were
worried about and I think the biggest
question that I think a lot of people
are gonna go into this with is did this
game to deserve a sequel right it was
the thing that everyone tried to figure
out was this game one where you know it
left on a fantastic note and is this
going to the well two too many times
with a sequel and I think that
scuttlebutt in and of itself is going to
be fantastic to dig through once people
get a chance
playing go through the whole thing so as
to not get sniped by by a Saudi ninja
that's all I'm gonna say for now well
I'm gonna try to get a review up that's
kind of gives you some good points on
some of that stuff before embargo does
you know right an embargo as well so
yeah I'm excited to hear what everybody
else has to think about it too for sure
yeah I mean I think personally the thing
that stood out most to me that I can
talk about is just how fun the combat is
mmm like like the combat was I thought
pretty good in Last of Us one but I
understand why people didn't like it and
I thought it was clunky or maybe it
frustrated them a little bit like I
totally got that but I saw what Naughty
Dog was going for with the first one and
I was like okay this combat works it's
very hefty and it totally works
and with this sequel I'm amazed at how
much fun I've been having just loading
up encounters and just fighting through
enemies because Ellie yourself feels so
scrappy like she can she can craft
different items on the fly and like set
up traps and you very much have to use
this sort of hit-and-run tactics where
you take out someone kind of noisy and
then you sprint and hide and wait for
them to settle down a little bit and
then you go in and pick off another
person and that feels so satisfying but
the weird thing about it is that it is
also so brutal that I almost feel bad
that I am enjoying this combat so much
because like I think Kelly you'd
mentioned it before like occasionally an
enemy will drop to their knees and beg
for forgiveness but I'm just so in the
moment that I'm like oh we're gonna
clear this whole place out there and
like hitting them with like spike the
bats and stuff and like the camera
pushes in as you can as the back
connects with their face and it is
absolutely gruesome but it is fun it is
really fun and it makes me bummed that
there's no multiplayer component because
yes I think a multi because I thought
the multiplayer component in the
original Last of Us was really good in
not enough people gave it a shot and I
like imagining what a multiplayer
component component would be like in
this gets me really excited but at the
same time I didn't want Naughty Dog
worked way too hard on this game as is
probably don't yeah you
what I'm trying to say yeah I would say
that fun is not has not really been my
experience um the first couple nights I
played I had nightmares Wow
because I was playing for most of the
day so I ended up having to space it out
a lot more it's very intense
and I found myself I mean it's very
tense also I just felt very tense and I
feel like like fun fun is that the word
that I personally would used to describe
how I felt about it like the combat in
particular Ellie yes is very scrappy I I
I played on hard and I I felt like every
every comment encounter I was like
barely scraping by is how I felt like
just every every time I got out of a
fight I'd be like oh my god okay I
definitely got that too because I was
playing on Survivor and oh my god you're
both mad people my first playthrough I
was like I can do this and it was
probably a mistake like if you're
picking this game up day one I would not
recommend doing survivor first
playthrough because I died a lot and
like Kathy was saying every after every
battle I was like I'm amazed I made it
but part of me really like that too you
know it if you play in the harder
difficulties or if you adjust some of
the difficulty it's not throwing all
these bullets and stuff at you like you
really have to think how you can take
down enemies and it does feel like a
puzzle it's like okay I've got two
bullets I've got enough to maybe make a
Molotov and maybe I can make a smoke
bomb how can I get past like six enemies
with that and then you kind of have to
decide like alright who's the biggest
threat who's who's not so much a threat
and then you have to kind of navigate
through that area and I found that super
satisfying which is a big reason why I
like to last us one so much on harder
difficulties and I think it works even
better and last of us too because the
arena's are so much more open and they
allow for more exploration and there's
like different routes throughout it
anyway sorry Kelly continued
yeah she's gonna say aye I was very I
was I had a hard time sleeping after
playing I part of the problem is that I
was working all day and then playing at
night I don't have time during the day
to play the games I'm reviewing
unfortunately I do a lot of the playing
after work and that meant I was playing
at night and I was having a hard time
sleeping I ended up having to play
animal crossing to sleep detox with
animal crossing that's rain says yeah
and and I think because I was very
emotionally invested the the tricky
thing is that there's a lot of very
brutal violence like it isn't even just
like enemies that beg fruit you to spare
them it's like you shoot someone and if
you don't get a head shot they like
scream or you can hear them drowning in
their own blood or you can see someone's
face when Ellie stabs them in a stealth
kill like because that's the way the
cameras oriented it is really graphic
and I I don't know that that was the
reason I was so invested in the story I
feel like like for example the girl
who's playing the Vita that we all saw
in that trailer or extended gameplay I
guess that's just a cutscene I had no
choice about what was gonna happen to
her I too had to watch la kill her and
and that was the stuff that impacted me
and drew me into the story a lot more
than the things I was doing I just found
it like I found it satisfying to
successfully navigate those arenas like
Jake's talking about like figuring out
how to get Ellie from point A to point B
without dying with limited resources I
really like playing stealth so I had a
field day like trying to figure out okay
you're here but you're coming this way
so like I have to use an arrow I can't
you know or whatever
but I found a lot of the things that I
had to do to be really unpleasant in a
way that I don't know if it serves the
story necessarily I think a lot of that
stuff the the the the gut punches and
stuff that happens in cutscenes mm-hmm
so you know like the introduction of
dogs is a great example
I think much it much was made a big deal
was made about killing the dogs it's
probably not as many as you think but um
I don't what I I do and I don't see the
point of that as far as like how the
gameplay brings me into the story that's
something that's really important to me
in games I really love it when the
gameplay is an active part of the
narrative I think one of the things I
find that's so important in games is
because that's something only games can
do when they're telling a narrative this
is something I've talked about at length
about undertale i think like undertale
has to be a game you know well same with
like the first last of us to write like
one of the big things about that game
was that the gameplay was so heavily
tied into the narrative and it all made
sense it wasn't just like all right
killer room full of guys then we're
gonna have a cutscene kill a room full
of guys cutscenes because in the first
left of us and I guess this is spoilers
for the original last of us you know
when you get to the end of that game and
you are so attached to Ellie and you
want to protect her and you want to save
her and you you know that Joel is is
making a bad decision a a morally gray
if not poor decision but you are right
there with him and you want to make that
decision with him because you want to
say that Lee and that was to me
something that was so powerful about the
Last of Us was that like I I wanted to
do that you know that's kind of [ __ ]
up like I wanted to do that the thing
that I experienced in the Last of Us
part two is more often than not I did
not want to be doing the things that I
was doing
and that and the thing is like I did
them because I wanted to know where the
story was going I was so invested but
when it came to when it came down to
like actually doing the things that like
you don't have a lot of choice in the
matter
Ellie is very angry as has been touted
in the the pre-release material I was
just like god I wish I could reach into
my TV and shake her and tell her [ __ ]
don't want this is I know this is bad
news it wasn't like the first last mess
where I was like this is bad news but I
get it
yeah the last week or two is more like
oh we could be doing literally anything
else right now yeah that's really hard
to marry with the satisfaction that you
feel from overcoming enemies with the
destruction you leave in your wake and
wondering what the point of that
destruction is so that's my biggest
sticking point it feels a lot like when
I especially after you just share that
and it makes me reflect on the time that
I had but it makes me feel like less of
us one was the road in a lot of
different ways and last of us to is John
wick in a lot of ways you know and I
mean it and in that in that way and yes
I totally get that that idea or that
that concept around like the things that
you're doing it's a means to an end in a
way that doesn't feel great if you're
not a mass murderer so yeah it's totally
I get that that makes a lot of sense
yeah sorry JJ I I mean I I get what
you're saying like I def for background
I've played the game about two and a
half times now and I will say like on
the second playthrough I found it I very
good but but I I I totally get what
you're saying and I agree with you for
the most part but
do i do get why that violence is there
because I think it it really wants to do
a very specific thing that I can't talk
I know killing me and I'm with you those
but I I think it serves a purpose all of
that violence and I think it is very
powerful and I think what it is able to
do in the second half is is incredible
but there are definitely times where I
am totally with you where it's just like
Ellie why like we we didn't need to do
this like we could have we could have
done half this and they would have been
we could have made things in the
apocalypse divot I I just want to really
quickly say that yes I think playing it
again i i i will say i think it is a
fantastic character study and I am I'm
so emotionally entangled in it in such a
messy complex way that I really do love
so it's a very complicated game I didn't
touch it for a full week after finishing
it because I was just like I need to
please like I mean it is it's a lot it's
a lot I I when I finished my first
playthrough I was like I don't know if I
like this game like I love I love the
combat but I don't know if I like this
game
it wasn't until like replaying it
reflecting in reflecting and like
thinking about it more and and overall I
I have to say I think I I think it's got
moments where it almost hits the highs
of Last of Us one but overall I think
less times one is a better game in my
opinion and it's a game that I still
consider one of my favorites I don't it
might be too early to say with Last of
Us to right now I I like I remember
thinking about the first Last of Us game
for weeks if not months after playing
that game and I would tell
my friends like you have to play this
game I still do it to this day like I
saw friend today and I was like hey man
you got to play The Last of Us now that
you got a PlayStation David Ahmadi on
our video team I've been telling me to
play that game for years and he finally
played it a week ago and he was like
holy [ __ ] I can't believe I slept on
this game for this long and I overall I
I don't think it hits the highs that
last of us one did that being said I
think people concerned about whether or
not this game deserves a sequel or
whether it deserves a sequel i I think
it totally earns it I think it go where
it goes makes sense and it doesn't feel
like oh so knee just wanted another Last
of Us game because the first one did
well like it feels like this game has a
reason to be here and it has it has it
has a purpose yeah I think I think one
of the things that I came away from it
thinking about because I finished it
literally like 2:30 this morning
finished it late at night club thank you
headphones but it was one of those
things when I when I went to bed I was
like wow Naughty Dog like for all the
stuff that they you know get touted for
and and making great stories making
great narrative and building good
world's around characters that you wind
up caring about I think they made some
really bold choices not only with the
villainous of the combat but the the way
that they've told this particular story
seems not necessarily fresh but I think
it it hits notes that pull together
really good threads for things that you
cared about for a game that came out on
the ps3 right so it's like it's it's
very difficult to to make that kind of
seamless transition from one game to
something that's been in development for
a very long time and feel like it is the
continuous conversation that's happening
around a story with the people in it
that doesn't feel separated or
disjointed in any real way like they
told a really fantastic cohesive story
and that to me is is something to be
celebrated in and of itself to say like
Bravo and kudos to a team that has been
doing this work
well for a long time with lots of people
who had lots of ideas of what this game
was gonna wind up being just by seeing
the initial presentations for what got
shown from a PR perspective I think I
think they did a really good job in
terms of tying up all those things
together and having a really smart
well-done story that that people can I
don't know if you would necessarily
relate cuz I don't think most people
relate but there there are parts of the
story that absolutely like hit those
bones points for you so yeah Bravo to
the team they think did a fantastic job
I want to ask Michael we have to be
really vague are we making any sense
oh yeah no no like real talk like cuz I
played less of us one so this is all
like it's churning and like I've been
paying attention to the last was to like
preview stuff all the way up to this
point I think I said last week that I'm
just I'm just ready to play this game
because it's kind of a known quantity
and then with what y'all are saying I'm
like this all makes sense like I can see
just from the preview stuff I'm piecing
it together so yeah like the thing that
y'all keep mentioned is like the way the
camera works hmm I think that like
camera work has been a huge thing and a
lot of like the way persona 5 is able to
communicate certain things with the way
it uses camerawork and cut-ins and all
this other stuff to show to emphasize
certain things I can see that I already
saw like in the extended gameplay that
they've shown before but yeah it's just
like I can imagine what it's like for
Elia to stab someone in their eyeball
and be like boom well I could stab you
in your eyeball like look at it look at
the eyeball I don't know if you stab
eyeballs in but I understand the way in
which it's showing you that thing and
I'm someone who's like yeah I play a lot
shooters and I think about like games
such as doom where the violence is so
over-the-top it's so you're killing
demons you're ripping them and tearing
them apart in half and it's kind like
haha that's kind of funny even though it
looks semi it has like a very realistic
sort of look
but something about even just last of us
one dude like cool boy especially that
lat like the final final sequence that
y'all were talking about earlier it's
the violence in a game like Last of Us
in Last of Us 2 is sends a very
different message than violence you see
in normal shooters and if they're
leaning into that I don't think it's
like I don't think I'm gonna be
comfortable with that but I do like what
from what y'all been saying it sounds
like that is part of the experience and
that's part of what they're trying to do
so yeah it's definitely part of the
experience I I would just say like the
the question is is how effective a part
of the experience is sure yeah and how
like because overall I I really
connected with this game in a way that
was like haunting to me sure and so I
can't deny that yeah and like I don't
think that media needs to be happy or
like I don't think shying away from
violence is necessary I just there's
like a disconnect to me because I mean
it was really it was just really hard to
play yeah I I when you said that like
the what you like most about what I like
most about games is when the gameplay
connects with the message message that
it's trying to send so that's definitely
something I'm gonna be mindful of when I
do play this game because that is like
you may have hey you dropped undertale
name-dropping anytime you know all about
that but yeah that is a case in which
those two are their intended they're
designed in tandem so I don't know I've
said and played last it was two yet but
I am excited to sort through my own
feelings cuz it sounds like you all have
still have a lot more sorting to do with
your own feelings
oh yeah that's exciting regardless I
don't know how to talk about it like
it's harder it's so hard like I think
the best way to sum it up is like what
you saying Khalif is like well the first
one was like the road this is more like
John wick and then what Callie was
saying like this is like first and
foremost the character study and I maybe
not first and foremost but I think like
that is the bulk of this story and and I
think it works and like you were saying
like almost hauntingly it works like I
just want to see the folders in
whoever's desktop that did the vo that's
all grunts and screams like 7,000 kids
maybe terabytes of grunts and screams
[Applause]
you probably have seen the like preview
stuff where like people like all of the
villains have enemies have names and
they'll like shout their fallen friend's
name yeah and like somebody had to like
don't do a bunch of vo saying a bunch of
different people's names as if they had
died like that Steve yeah so did you
feel like that was effective though like
I know a lot of people were talking
about that as being a part of the the
emotional feel that was gonna bring you
into the world in a real way did you
feel like that actually affected you in
a real way that see that is the most
helpful question because that that that
is what I'm talking about when I talk
about the violence not really getting me
there a hundred percent of the way I did
not feel that giving them Nate like
giving them names didn't change how I
was like I gotta kill all of you I mean
first of all I have looting to do so you
have to die so there are gameplay
elements there like it Moses is so hard
to talk about
in one sense yes that was effective mmm
but moment to moment
I don't think it completely hit for me
I keep I keep tapping over to the - like
what I could talk about and I'm like but
it's so hard to explain why it's
important to explain why but I will say
this though really quickly I think that
Naughty Dog missed a huge opportunity by
not having one of the enemies named
Felicia so you can kill them and say bye
Felicia
during the process Naughty Dog you've
missed the boat on that literally
meanwhile they managed to get in smash
Brandy's couch I forgot you can see
somebody's pornographic videotape
collection and one of the titles is
called smash Brandy's couch that's not
even realistic it should be like I don't
know it's not even like big web but some
[ __ ] like wait I'm just making that up
please don't look at mansion that search
anyway oh they did manage so they could
have put it in a Felicia or whatever I
feel like I killed several David's just
and that's not that's not a spoiler
because they are not actual it's it's
hard because like they're not like
actually named characters they're just
like a guy they were really Eurocentric
names - that was an interesting the
thing that'll be talking about that
that's a good thing to know it's like
you know there was nobody with like a
lot in their names and nothing like that
like there was none as like actual like
other people it was not a very diverse
name a grouping when it came to that
kind of it's weird because the game
itself is like pretty different like the
main cast it's incredibly diverse yeah
but yeah you don't really kill a lot of
people with not Anglo names one thing I
do want to say is
I wonder if like because I played on sir
playing on Survivor meant that I
couldn't kill everyone in loot every
area a lot of areas I just had to run
through I had to like pick my battles
and just run so I wonder if like that
sort of I don't know balancing act
between the gameplay and the story
worked a little bit better for me
because a lot of enemies I straight-up
didn't kill because I simply couldn't so
it was like I only killed the people who
were directly in my way or who I saw as
the threat other than that I would just
keep moving which maybe it is worth
trying on Survivor if you're feeling
confident cuz or if you're worried about
the issue Callie's talking about because
I definitely was not like clearing out
areas it was I very much had to choose
my battles part of the thing that
complicates that is the existence of
collectibles and loot exactly so I
screwed myself over so it's not just the
violence by itself it's how the violence
interacts with the game's emphasis on
exploration and collectibles so it's
like I enjoy getting collectibles and I
really like the you know I loved the oh
my gosh what was his name in the
original Last of Us ish I loved the ish
storyline and so I was looking I was
looking for storylines like that so I
was basically like swinging the camera
around everywhere I went trying to catch
things in my periphery the issue with
that is because the arena's are more
open and there's not a lot of
collectibles necessarily in combat heavy
zones but there are there are so have
and that is that's where it trips me up
because it's like okay in order to to
loot and discover these like little
world building tidbits I have to kill
everyone and in order to get more
materials I have to kill everyone in
most cases so that it's that interaction
it's helping to talk about it because
like we said at the beginning it's so
hard to parse but it's that overall
interaction between exploration and
combat that I think really effects
the flow of combat and the effect of
combat and I would say I do really I
liked picking up those little world
building tidbits there's some really
cool ones but Dave is like it is like
they I try that have an ish in every
single area like there's every areas got
its own little like subplot that has
just told through the environment and
notes which i think is I think is really
cool I like that but with the level
design being more open it resulted in me
doing a lot of like 360s and then
backtracking and checking rooms and I
ended up one thing I did really want to
talk about I ended up enabling one of
the many accessibility options the game
has a ton of accessibility options
obviously I haven't tried this because I
don't I'm not low vision but there you
could apparently play it completely if
you are blind with all of the like that
there are robust accessibility options
the one that I ended up enabling was
something called high contrast mode so I
could highlight collectibles because I
was so tired I would only turn it on
once I had cleared a room because it
highlights enemies also and I didn't
really want that because I wanted more
challenge in the combat not less but so
I would clear a room and then I would
enable high contrast mode and that way I
wasn't bumping into stuff trying to get
the prompt to trigger and that isn't the
most elegant solution because it
completely takes gets rid of all the
textures and stuff and so you're you're
taking taken out of the world since the
most graceful solution there's also
enhanced listening mode which lets you
ping for items I found that to be less
effective than high contrast mode and I
also didn't like that the prompt would
come up when I was just trying to use
listen mode so yeah the collectable
finding encouraged me to kill all the
enemies but what what do I get out of
that so it's it was the whole thing
yeah and you read a lot in this game you
read a lot and I read a lot I love I
love that Jake will tell you I love
doing the boring [ __ ] I'm like I'm gonna
feed every tooltip like I I'm gonna read
every note I I read every journal entry
you know like Ellie has a journal and I
loved it
it really provides a lot of insight into
her and so like that that's all fine I
took the time to read the journal and
that didn't disrupt it it was really
just like the okay I've killed all the
enemies in this area time to walk
through the area I wasn't in yes part of
that is my place so but part of that is
just how the game encourages you by
leaving these issues in every area to
keep looking for them so yeah this is
how so much talking yes seriously I
think I can actually write my review
doesn't spoil everything for sure we've
been going on for a while now but we
also have a topic we want to get to and
we have some listener questions which I
do want to get to this week because we
didn't have a chance to do them last
week so why don't we go through this
topic fairly quickly I feel like we've
had a question similar to this but the
PlayStation 5 reveal event happens
tomorrow this goes up Friday we don't
know what's gonna happen I figure we can
just kind of go around the room and
share some predictions we might have I
can kick this off my prediction is that
we're gonna see horizon zero dawn to
that's the the game that I think we're
gonna see I don't think it'll be a
launch title maybe they'll say it's
gonna be a launch title but I don't
think that is a launch title game like I
feel like it's gonna be way too big to
see day one on the console but that's my
big prediction whoever's gotten the
other ones feel free to just jump in you
I think they're gonna show the box for
sure they gotta show the box at this
point yeah III hope they show what last
of us to looks like on a PlayStation 5
and know that that will eat into the the
normal sales but I also think it might
get people really excited for pre-orders
in that way and I do think that we may
get a run-through of just like the
minutiae of how not necessarily UI is
gonna look but how those systems are
gonna interact with each other in a real
way so I'm hoping that that's gonna be a
thing in there too
I want to see price I don't think
they're gonna talk about price quite yet
like cos said we got to see you got to
see what it looks like no sharp edges
please it hurts to move around my ps4
because I got delicate hands what I want
to see what the box looks like I think
an important thing is showing some of
the Microsoft has been very good about
communicating their quality of life
features around the 1x not necessarily
like oh this is this is our robust power
or whatever but they've been really good
about talking about what smart delivery
is how bad compat is going to work all
the other features on the side they're
gonna make playing games on that system
so much more easier and a lot more
enjoyable so I want to see Sony
communicate some of that if that is part
of the PS 5 such as that create button
what what is that why did you change
share to create does that mean I'm gonna
be able to cut things up differently
before I share them on social media can
i download premier on my PS 5 hey listen
if I'm still working off my PS 5 let's
go but yeah things around the edges in
terms of games I mean they're gonna show
games I just don't have any idea as to
what they what they won't be maybe we'll
see more God fall or whatever but I am
personally more interested in how the PS
5 is going to function traction
predictions unless Nintendo predictions
in which case I am a psychic yeah III
honestly I really don't have a mind for
marketing so I just I'm I'm like uh
maybe they'll show some color options
but just think I'm so bad of it that's
alright that's fine but I the other
thing is it's more complicated when it's
like oh I've played a game that's not
out are they gonna show things that I
know already like that it's complicated
so and also I've just been like I
haven't even been looking at stuff
because I've been so busy trading items
on Nick is on and then trying to sort
through my sadness about the apocalypse
meeting the game not really I mean could
be interchangeable though all right well
let's move on to listener questions then
if you've got any questions you can
email us at after dark podcast at
GameSpot comm or you can join into
discord server we have a whole channel
there where people can just ask
questions and for the most part we try
to pull those questions
however we are a bit behind because last
week we ended up cutting that section so
we're gonna go through some questions
that may seem a little dated if you're a
listener who submitted these questions
that are kind of a while ago but anyway
Kelly do you want to read the first one
sure this is from Friedman on discord I
wanted to ask all of you guys what do
you believe the pros and cons are to
video game journalism I'm sure some of
the pros are being able to play games
early and to be some of the first people
to see them before anyone else does but
on the other hand it must be difficult
having to tailor your thoughts so that
they translate easily for viewers and
readers and do you feel any amount of
pressure giving games people may be
really looking forward to a certain
score I'm gonna go first and say that
I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick
and then y'all can tell the bright
amongst yourselves I'm very sorry I will
meet my mic good I will say that I think
the pros for me have definitely been
like the people that I meet doing this
job I this is gonna sound really sappy
for him and if so bear with me I I
really did not have a lot of friends
growing up I didn't know a lot of other
girls that played video games or who
would admit to playing video games doing
this line of work was the first time I
was able to talk to other girls about
games in a real way and that was really
powerful for me so that
huge plus I've met most of my favorite
people through this job so that has
always been a big plus I I don't think
about the getting games early thing too
much just because I was never like well
no that's not true I was like day one
for certain games but for me there's way
more pressure involved with getting a
game early then there is benefit and to
the second question the second part of
this question I absolutely do feel
pressure I I don't let it affect me like
I've never like given okay like I
wouldn't ever give a score just because
I thought that's what people wanted to
hear but reviewing games has been a very
it's a laborious experience and you
often get more [ __ ] than you do reward
for it and it's gotten to the point
where I get anxiety before I publish
anything and so yes I would say I
absolutely feel a lot of pressure before
reviewing a game I feel pressure both
from fans who I know are going to tweet
at me and from people in the industry
who tend to broadcast their opinion of a
game ahead of time like based on the
promotional material I don't know if you
guys can relate to that but the Twitter
games media twitter circle will kind of
be talking about a game ahead of time
and I feel a lot of pressure like oh am
I going to be considered an idiot for
liking this game or like a rube or
whatever it's it's actually a very big
issue in my in Mike my job is navigating
the stresses of the social pressures
around your opinion mmm yeah that's
fantastic I mean it not Finn says that
you feel that pressure but if instead
you shared that it's the interesting
part for a show like ours and for me as
a person who's so I still consider
myself
weirdly new to the industry in a lot of
different ways even
like over the years it's probably like
ten years now from blog to podcast to
doing all the stuff we were talking a
little bit about access for things on
another show and I feel like for a
smaller outfit like us you feel an
immense amount of pressure to do a
review that will get you to the next
review so that's a huge thing in there I
mean it does it hasn't compromised any
of my actual feelings towards the stuff
because if I'm giving you some kind of
BS version of my thoughts and it's not
genuinely me or I'm kind of doing my
audience a disservice but I think it's
absolutely there and I totally agree
with you daily about the pressure that
you put on yourself to one finish a
thing really quickly because you have
these really tight deadlines I remember
a ditch that's trending was no joke
getting that thing done in the amount of
time that I was able to get it done
while having a nine-to-five job and
trying to be a reasonable husband and
the other things so yeah like you have a
lot of pressure that just goes along
with that part of it but I do think that
the the benefits are again the people
that you get a chance to meet a gate
like being a journalist or being in the
press and in doing this kind of work and
being on the media side gave me an
infinitely more Givi infinitely more
appreciation for the craft of making a
game and for the people who do it in
this industry it's the reason why GDC is
my favorite gaming conference is because
you get to see all these brilliant human
beings who could be using their brains
for anything else making games for
everybody at home just gonna get crapped
on that's another conversation but I
think that's a huge part of it is
getting a chance to meet some of your
peers and getting a chance to meet some
of your heroes and being able to have a
voice where you might not have had a
voice before which is huge for a lot of
folks who are starting this work in the
initial phases of getting into the
industry especially and then having
people like appreciate what you actually
have to say is huge for a person who is
I mean I'm a huge introvert most people
don't know that
but you know getting a chance to feel
like you have a space to be able to
emote and talk about a thing that you
love that you've grown up with for God
at this point thirty years for me is
huge and a big benefit to everyone who's
in that space so I often feel more lucky
than anything to be able to be doing a
thing I love and talking about a thing I
love because a lot of people don't get a
chance to do that so that's that's the
biggest thing for me yeah I'm back you
know it's funny to tie this back to kha
is that you asked me this question yeah
when I was on spawn on me so I would
encourage folks to if you want to get my
full answer the to go check out spawn on
me and multiple things that that cod
does there but I'll give it real quick
because I know that we're we got still
got more stuff to go through but pros
like like I said the social aspect
meeting your peers to having a voice and
then three not just having a voice but
to this can cut both ways in where my
hobby is now my job hmm that can create
some and with a lot of people will do
this talk about this a lot and it can
cut both ways in that you don't
necessarily get that separation from
work but for me it's like I'm going to
play games in my free time regardless
and the the fact that these experiences
that I'm having on my own time that
might not be an assignment is going to
feed into my work in some way and that
regard my free time is also more
fulfilling I think I like that a lot
about being able to do this and also the
the social aspect not just because like
oh we got to meet dope people and like
chop it up at events and all that and
turn up whatever but they the people I
have been able to connect with have
taught me a lot just by interacting with
them I also mentioned this as well that
folks that you like a lot of progressive
voices in games media and that's a
definite pro for me because it's a
learning experience I talked about this
when I mentioned you know for example my
love for a game like persona 4 golden I
played in 2017 but I
learned so much since then because of
the discourse the genuine discourse that
has happened between the time I played
the game and now so and then there's a
lot of yeah a lot of folks that I follow
have spoken up about multiple subjects
about that and just listening to them
reading their work and hearing what they
have to say as made me grow as a person
so and if he wants how about cons I mean
you know the Twitter discourse this
morning saying that is gonna date itself
oh yeah we you might want to have you a
power the money discourse yeah money
discourse oh yeah so yeah that's another
thing too but overall like I'm there's
nowhere else I'd rather be nothing else
I'd rather be doing alright well let's
go into the next question Jake you
didn't answer I everyone gave such great
answers I don't know if I'll be able to
top those I mean I mean for the most
part I would make the fact that like
I've met so many great people doing this
and it was always so cuz growing up like
I had a lot of friends who played games
but they weren't super into games or
frankly a lot of friends who didn't play
games at all because it's like oh that's
that's nerdy so I've always kind of like
that's been a hobby of mine that I kind
of didn't really wear on my sleeve at
all I was like oh yeah play some games
and when I have free time but like being
at this job I thought was really cool
because it seems like almost everyone
shares the same passion and like a lot
of people I meet at different events and
conventions and whatnot have that same
passion so it's really exciting to be
able to talk about like like the
discussion we just had with the Last of
Us is something that I probably wouldn't
have had otherwise like I would have
maybe listen to some podcasts like I
remember the first game came out like
the only discussions I had about that
game were just me listening to people
talk about it so it's really cool to be
able to have that discussion with people
who think critically about games and
think more about games than just like oh
yeah games are fun like that is
incredibly rewarding and it's definitely
one of my favorite things one of the
cons I would say is oh man I I think
just a law
the kind of like what Michael was saying
a lot of discourse that happens in the
industries can be a lot especially on
Twitter like I definitely I feel like at
least a couple times a year I just have
to delete Twitter step away from it and
like just just get some distance because
if I think too hard about a lot of it I
get frustrated whether it's people just
being I don't know like clueless or like
just people getting mad at my friends
and stuff because they gave a game a
certain score and they didn't read the
review like that's something that
frustrates me beyond belief and that is
a big reason why a lot of times have to
step away from Twitter just because I
know how much work people put into their
reviews like Kali put so much work into
reviews Michael put so much work into
his reviews and then people will just
gravitate towards the score and then
they'll get a ton of [ __ ] over it and
that is that pisses me off a lot and I
wish we could do away with scores or
something or I wish people just be more
respectful because that is something
like to be fair that's something I
didn't really think about too when I was
just looking at IGN and GameSpot and
stuff before I worked here I didn't
realize how much time went into that and
I think part of that is because I'm like
oh they just play a game and then they
write a couple thousand words about it
but in actuality it's like that's all
you're doing for a very short period of
time and then you have to decompress you
have to reflect on it you have to figure
out what you're gonna write about then
you have to structure it you have to
like it is grueling it is absolutely
grueling and I think the abuse that
people get over it is is frustrating but
anyway that's my dear friend Jake cuz
like I review games like once every so
often - yeah you reviewed Xenoblade
Chronicles definitive edition that you
also review The Witcher 3 on switch oh
yeah I did but those were like well
Xenoblade Chronicles I was worried about
because the fans can be very vocal and
madis but witcher i was like not super
concerned
because it was like I've played this
game eight times I know I know this game
like the back of all I'm doing is just
seeing how it runs and it's pretty much
writing about how it still holds us that
I was a little less concerned about but
occasionally like we'll get videos where
someone will be very earnest and like
like Jordan did a video about gamerscore
and how Xbox can hopefully kind of
rework that and it got so much crap on
YouTube and it was just like it was like
a very short like made a lot of sense he
was like hey I'm tired of games having
like achievements that are worth three
gamer score and messing everything up
and I was like and I was really cool it
was so that drives me crazy - I totally
get it and and then of course it comes
out and everyone's like like just
[ __ ] on it and it's just like come
on like it anyway I I do want to say one
thing on on the money aspect just
because like that has been a
conversation that people have been
having this week and I don't want to
totally glossed over it I actually did
want to wait for Michael to be back to
talk about it I I think you know there's
a lot of variation in pay in the
industry there doesn't really seem to be
like a standard like here's what you can
expect to make at this level the levels
of different websites are all different
titles mean different things at some
website associate editor is like a
really high position at GameSpot it is a
junior position or like a junior ish
position so it is very confusing there's
there's really no standardized way to
look at it as part of it but I think a
big thing is you know we talk about how
passionate we are and we talk about how
like we're basically working in our free
time because like I can come to work the
next day or open my laptop the next day
lately and be like like with nook azan
I've been doing nook is on like in all
in my free time and now I'm like I now I
have an article idea and so that does
turn it's not like it's not free time it
I think it doesn't mate many ways make
it more fulfilling because you feel like
okay I'm actually being a little
productive like I'm not totally wasting
my life like everyone
told me I was for my whole childhood but
but the thing about that that you have
to be careful of if you're thinking
about entering this industry is that a
company will want to take advantage of
you feeling lucky to do it and I tell
people when they ask me this all the
time you don't ever do work for free
because your work is worth something
your time is worth something and this is
a an issue across the industry and
frankly across many inch industries in
this late cap cross country yes across
capital but I want to encourage you like
it you yes it is a really cool job and
it is awesome in so many ways but it is
still work and don't ever let an editor
or a company make you feel like you
should just be lucky for a pittance I
think that's a big issue
and I think kind of to just jump off
that like if you are if you're in a
position where you feel like you have to
work over a weekend or something like
that or work extra I I think it's super
important to think like what what am I
gonna get out of this too because that's
something I've been doing a lot because
when I started this job I worked all the
time and now it's like come to that
point where like yeah I do play games in
my free time like currently I'm trying
to get all the collectables in the last
of us and I've been doing that a lot in
my free time but I'm asking myself too
like am I just doing this because it's
my job for GameSpot or am I gonna get
something out of this myself and if I
answer yes to that like yes I am getting
something out of it myself
then it's like okay there's I may not
getting paid for this time but there is
a purpose that I have found in it but if
it's like okay like there's this game
that we need coverage of or whatever and
and I'm playing it on the weekend and
I'm like there are so many things that I
should be doing right now
besides this then I'm like very quick to
be like all right this is not what I
should be doing I'm gonna step away and
wait until I am on the clock
but anyway
that was pretty inside baseball oh it
was contextualize what we do yeah
next question we'll keep this one short
this is from fogey bear he says let's
switch it up give songs albums or
artists you've been listening to as of
late why don't we just do like one
artist or album each so we can move on
next question and then we'll wrap this
up okay shouts out to fogey bear yeah
that's my guy so streaming a lot
recently
yeah I actually keep the stream yeah
check it out check it out it's really
good yeah Foca bears dope so I've been
this is actually Taizo someone else that
we know funky Joseph yeah I want to talk
about cat dog all right so funky and he
has a partner that he collaborates with
to make that makes up cat dog and cat
dog is a rap duo
they also produce their own stuff and
sample a lot of video game music
and I don't man damn I don't know what
to say
for context funky is a freelance writer
in the industry funky has done a lot of
really great work for GameSpot and a lot
of really great work elsewhere you might
have seen him on I think you will on
beyond that I Jan very recently he wrote
a fantastic piece about representation
and Animal Crossing and he does reviews
on top of that so um shout out to him
but he also a pick he's also really cool
in the music scene oh my god so I go to
ban Capcom slash CatDog CatDog tracks
actually tra X and it's just like this
mellow vibe of like hip-hop that's it's
funny as [ __ ] like it's the the lyricism
is so creative and it's God dance a
hilarious you know and those
instrumentals or on point it's so it's
so good and it's kind of like uplifting
because I found out about it
just like through his Twitter profiles I
you [ __ ] baton about music I'm going
to check out cat dog and then it was
just like this this serenus and it was
just so jolly and made me it uplifted me
they're like this is so relaxing and
it's funny as hell oh my god y'all need
to check out cat dog tracks so she how
it's a fun game thank you for that
that's dope
I've got I've been listening to rtj for
a lot which I've been enjoying and then
also crooked still just because of a
game I played recently me Ivan listen to
a bunch of Kate Renata I just go back
into that bag because it's super good
and and little brother has been getting
me through the past week so mad little
mad lb love in the world for them to I
this weird Fleetwood Mac kick but I only
listen to songs that Stevie Nicks roads
[Laughter]
that's great
and it wasn't you bought purpose it's
just the ones that I like happened to be
the ones she wrote one thing about cat
dog is so the album is what's the vibe
that's my favorite cat dog album and my
favorite song off of what's the vibe EP
is fatal Bert that fatal Bert work
alright we've got one more question here
what do y'all think we've been going for
almost an hour over an hour and a half
now yeah I think it's super quick all
right yes is this I wanted to have
Michael on when we answered this
question that's why I put it on last
week but you guys didn't get to it so
maybe we just have you into this
question Michael because I think you're
sure probably your host equipped
definitely the most call it right but
anyway this one's from Caleb come on off
the phone hey little bro well I'm
currently building my first ever PC just
impatiently waiting for all my parts to
arrive entirely new entirely new to PC
gaming so I was wondering if you had any
tip
so you may have for a PC and what are
some PC games you'd recommend
I already plan on playing disco Elysium
of how highly you praise it and because
it's a highly well because of how highly
you've praised it and my graphics cards
come with a monster hunter ice-born my
graphics card comes with Monster Hunter
ice-born also I was wondering about
joining that oh I hope I sent them a
discord invite on a senator discord
invite but anyway that's the question ah
damn what kinds of tips you have for PC
and what kind of PC yeah drivers
yeah update your drivers so it's always
gonna be a be a damn thing that you have
to worry about in terms of you know it's
it's gotten to the point where
everything is kind of cross-platform
in terms of release is like everything
is almost multi-platform but I think
that the the kind of staples PC gaming
if you want again to mmo's I have this
game called Final Fantasy 14 over real
talk like if you want to try something
that's very specific to pcs maybe in if
you're interested try to find an MMO
that works for you
I know consoles have adapted that but
it's a very different experience on PC I
think you know giving exclusives such as
like counter-strike a shot to see if
that's like your vibe because they've
come out on consoles but it's totally
not the same there are there are games
that specifically need to be played on
PC and as the years have gone on that's
been less and less the case but you do
if you have a high-end PC you definitely
get the best experience in my opinion so
yeah definitely check those those kinds
of things out you know
Boba's if you're I'm not into mobile I'm
not into MOBAs but you might be and
those are also PC exclusive types of
games such as B legends
I don't feel about that but - here's the
storm things like that RTS is like if
this is your first ever PC build [ __ ]
with some RTS is real-time strategy
games first to see if that's your thing
as well
there again there are console versions
of art CSS but they are not the same
experience as having keyboard and mouse
so like check out like command & Conquer
they just remastered some of the early
games it's some people say it's kind of
a dead issue onra but that doesn't
negate the fact that real-time
strategies have such a rich history so
definitely check that out
games like Total War that are also PC
exclusive that you won't get on consoles
if that's your thing if none of that
clicks then you still have the strongest
platform to play multi-platform games
and multiplayer shooters I personally
think they're the best once you get used
to the keyboard and mouse such as I play
apex on on PC keyboard mouse is where
it's at
[Music]
siege on PC you know I'm saying it just
makes the things that you need to do in
those games so much more fluid so you're
less fighting with the controls and more
doing the things that you want to do so
definitely dip your toes and some of
those PC specific genres but then you
know try out some shooters and see if
you like that experience a lot more on
PC otherwise a hit book hit monster
hunter ice-born hit up final fantasy xiv
there's a free trial up until level 35
word on the street is I'm paying for
subscriptions I don't know if that's
true let me know especially correct me
if I'm wrong but that's a that's a Lao
last name so shout out to my jungle
agents out there and yeah hit me up if
you have any other questions cuz this is
a actually like a really good question
for those who are dipping their toes
into an all-new platform with so many
possibilities real quick addition to
that as Anna former IT professional
backup all your stuff
backup your system as soon as you get it
so this place as soon as you build it
out and you have all the apps and all
that stuff back it up put nothing on a
drive and put it in a drawer somewhere
where you can find it later saves your
behind numerous numerous times I also
want to give a shout-out to my favorite
games to play on PC which are management
sims city builders and strategy games
um they I vastly prefer them on PC
obviously like if the Sims is your thing
you want to do that on PC like these
kinds of games were the reason I played
on PC growing up so I love tech kun
games you could play like planets ooh
you could do civilization you could you
could [ __ ] with city skylines all sorts
of stuff and I think we should give a
special shout out to divinity original
sin - we did get a 10 out of 10 on
GameSpot so that's another one that I
think is very well suited to PC
specifically one more thing yeah I one
thing I do in a die mods mods scene or a
lot of mono PC look for look for a game
that you may really like that you played
on PlayStation or whatever I start early
like starting valley or new the witcher
is a good one you you can you can make
that game whatever the hell you want it
to be that erm like more often than not
i download all these mods play for 20
minutes i'm like that but like sometimes
you'll find something and you'll be like
holy [ __ ] this is really fun and then
you'll just get sucked back into it The
Witcher 3 with all of the mods like
they're kind of small but like basically
you can make a very cinematic version of
that game which I had a lot of fun
playing really quick before Mike jumps
back in one of the coolest games to
actually model that did not know until
very recently as NBA 2k actually it's a
really good to mod that game out because
one the character models are kind of
bootybuttcheeks if you did not get to
scan them incorrectly so people have
been doing the work of re-upping really
good facial good faces for people and
you can change the way that the whole UI
looks to make it replicate or mimic the
sub you see on on broadcast TV as well
so that's a really cool thing that
you'll be able to do from its UK
perspective for sure last thing I'm
going to say about this is that keep in
mind that PC PC's backlog goes back to
forever
alright this is in a console generation
you go back to the games that came out
like an
90s 80s whatever so try and seek out
some of the like the the games that have
been regarded as the most pivotal games
in history or whatever and give them a
shot even though they might be dated or
whatever I think that it's also if
you're into pee now that you have a PC
that can play games it's important to
like try and look back and see some of
those classics one thing one game that
I'll say off the top of my head is Deus
Ex which was my favorite game for a very
long time that hasn't had a proper
console port it came out of ps2 but it
wasn't the same and that game has a ton
of mods whatever to make it feel a
little bit more modern but keep in mind
that those are like games like System
Shock 2 you can still play and black
mesa black mesa a they redid all of
half-life's and half-life is such an
important game especially now nowadays
so definitely look into that see if
anything piques your interest there so
all right well I think that's a good
spot to end episode 45 of games but
after dark thank you all so much for
listening and thank you Callie for
joining us it was an absolute pleasure
to have you here happy we got it got it
work in this is so much fun you're all
amazing I'm so happy to get a chance to
rock with y'all so again thank you so
much for having me and please if you
have an open spot please let me come
through and I can say bootybuttcheeks at
least one day do you have anything you
want to plug feel free to lay it all out
let's hear it yeah I've been on God
knows how many things this past week
again you know thank you to everyone
who's letting me jump on your show and
hijack it for at least the time that
I've been there so thank you to
everybody who's doing that work I'll be
on beyond next week as well so that'll
be a lot of fun over on on IGN's podcast
network aka the big the big show over
there too what else am i doing we have a
front page think never doing on Twitch
and of course the stuff over at YouTube
our latest show a lesson in blackness
has gone I guess viral in some ways a
lot of folks have been on that
conversation and and kind of pushing
that thing as well so a lot of a lot of
love to everyone who's been giving me
so when spawning me love and and
figuring out good ways to showcase the
the conversations we've been having so
again thank you to everyone here
GameSpot y'all a fam you always you
always come through and always give me
love when I better get a chance to rock
with y'all so again thank you so much
for having me on and hanging it was it
was awesome to see spawn on me on the
front page of twitch to I don't even
think I saw the tweets I just like
logged on the twitch and I was like holy
[ __ ] they got this they got it going on
the front page well I mean you all were
the first folks to give us front page
love to be honest to give us a place to
be able to have this conversation and
with the huge audience that you all have
so I owe you all a big bunch of credit
for that work and understanding that we
were trying to do something very
different in the space so thank you very
much for that and in massive love to you
and the rest of the crew thank you yeah
thank you for making it thank you it's
been a week I it's funny because like I
know we've been talking to you to you
about coming on the podcast for awhile
and it's like of course it's coming
during like the big biggest busiest week
you've had like oh finally we have an
open spot but we swear we it was part of
the plan all along we have been in talks
for long periods of time everyone in the
GameSpot community it's not because it's
just that show it was really awesome
that you guys did that and it's just
even better that you're able to talk
about it on after dark now and and get
even more attention to it for those who
didn't get to see thank you oh yeah I
did really appreciate how in that
episode you were like you'll never put
this on the front page like this just
isn't something which puts on the front
page and I was watching it on the front
page when that happened and I was like
all right let's go check hey you gotta
talk things into existence that's the
thing about the industry you talk things
into existence and they sometimes happen
for sure
Kelly what about you what do you want to
where can people find you what are you
working on I mean the big word we've
already talked about but yeah obviously
I would love for you all to read my Last
of Us
view this one we have spoilers so it's
safe and obviously you just listen to us
talk about it but it'll be the polished
version of what you heard so I mean it
is it's totally done already you can
find me on Twitter at a key tojiko I nky
DOJ ikk Oh again my god I wish I could
change that and yeah I guess just thank
you all for listening and to those who
have been joining for a play for all we
did something on Monday and we got a ton
of donations to both black lives matter
and to Direct Relief for kovat so thank
you again to everybody who joined in for
that we're still doing it over the next
couple weeks and so we're just
encouraging people to support those
causes it's something that we've you
know been doing internally and we really
believe in it so yeah that's not I'm not
on a lot of the play for all stuff but
that's something that I would love for
everybody to check out Michael how about
you you can find me and all of my
[ __ ] at Michael P hi I'm on Twitter
I I am wiling out on Twitter man know
the [ __ ] vibes and yeah I think that
you know I actually want to spend this
time to say that y'all should seek out
Black Voices I said this on the previous
podcast I say there's so many other
podcast I think I should have been
saying saying it for awhile but there
are so many great creators just some for
some stars obviously spawn on me I mean
I got to collab a Khalif again yeah look
at us look at us who would have thought
no boy like black girl gamers are out
there I love gaming Illuminati is not
the tbh the black ACOG a TV age yeah TV
it's Tanya to pass is one of like
someone that I value I value very much
in terms of like what she has to say
about the industry overall so definitely
seek still seek those voices out no
matter what what's happening in the
world what time it is seek them out
because they're out there and doing a
lot of good work so that's it
cool and that did you plug your Twitter
Khalif did you Oh
Katja Kenz k HJ h ki NS kins makes it
cute and that's well at spawn on me is
the show Twitter so you can find us
there on all podcast platforms YouTube
Instagram is spawn to be podcast if you
want to come see me
flourish trap myself out in the world
that's not true see my big ass rolling
around the only way I get to people
Islands this is like well anyway that's
been episode 45 games but f doc thank
you all so much for watching and we will
see
[Music]